لدى وصوله الى اجتماع قمه المجتمع السياسي
الاوروبي قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي ان الاولويه القصوى لاوكرانيا هي
تعزيز دفاعها الجوي وانه من الضروري توفير
درع دفاعي لبلاده خلال فصل الشتاء لمواجهه
الضربات
الروسيه اعتقد ان التحدي الاكبر هو ما
تقوم به روسيا من خلال المعلومات المضلله
والمزيفه ومن المهم جدا بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
ان يكون لديها درع دفاعيه للفصل القادم
لانه في الشتاء سنتعرض لهجمات بانواع
مختلفه من الصواريخ الروسيه بما في ذلك
الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره وغيرها واعتقد
اننا في اوكرانيا لا نخاف حاليا من فكره
الحرب الشامله الوقت قد فات اما بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده فاننا نعمل على الحصول
على دعم الحزبين واعتقد ان هذا مهم بالطبع